[Musique]
si vous ne cessiez l'opéra kdr
poussiéreux de notre temps et à des
chanteuses qui ressemble à la castafiore
détrompez-vous
désert nouveau et un vent de fraîcheur
souffle sur le terrain on a une espèce
d'image oui de l'opéra qui a été
transmise dans l'est dans la culture
populaire qu'on voit plus dans les films
cette image la plus lointaine puis un
peu
mais en fait c'est vraiment pas ça la
gatinoise de 27 ans est en résidence à
l'atelier lyrique de l'opéra de montréal
un tremplin important début de carrière
pour la crème des chanteurs d'ici avant
elle marie josée lord étienne dupuis et
marc hervieux sont passés par l'atelier
lyrique quand on se met ensemble
des harmoniques je trouve que
une espèce de quête de sens en quête de
beauté
actuellement elle travaille sur une
création de rené-daniel dubois
chaque année l'opéra montréal présente
deux à trois oeuvres nouvelles les
histoires contes qu'on veut garder en
mémoire on les chante pour les graver
sur une qu'à
l'université de montréal on vient même
de créer la première chaire consacrée à
la recherche et à la création en opéra
la professeure et compositrice à massat
colovic entend bien prouver que l'opéra
est un art total bien vivants qui
abordent des thématiques bien de son
temps on peut pas ignorer à toutes les
questions sociales économiques mouvement
mis tout mais pourtant vous allez avoir
encore aujourd'hui les opéras les
nouveaux opéra qui vont
devoir sacrifier une femme qui doit de
voir mourir parce qu'elle a montré sa
sensualité elle et ses étudiants vont
collaborer avec l'opéra montréal pour
créer des spectacles en réalité
virtuelle et augmentée la les
préoccupations de tous les artistes de
tous les temps est ce qu'ils vont faire
à l'opéra depuis 400 ans de faire tout
ce qu'on connaît tous ceux dont on
dispose
ensemble on synergie pour faire vivre
des émotions fortes
avec ces nouveaux outils montréal et sur
une ère d'allée et entend rester une
destination innovantes en matière
d'opéra je suis aussi certain que le
soleil va se lever dans l'est demain que
l'opéra sera ici pour des siècles je
suis dispo
ici nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal
[Musique]